bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fan i j
oggi siamo su è più il mio dio da mente
che non faccio episodi su happy meals
sarà tipo 2 settimane ragazzi scusatemi
veramente tantissimo ma tra uno speciale
l'altro non sono riuscito a fare più
direi di iniziare la cade poco challenge
quest'ora che tipo gli imposti può solo
che non si chiama impossible 16 steve
dopo tutti sti giannini l'attività ce la
facciamo
vai così vai così cazzo ho preso la mia
gamba e cos'è ragazzi e ragazze imposti
certo livello è ok ok ok sono passi
avanti sono passi avanti sono passi
avanti si no raga dove cazzo è il
traguardo ma non c'è il traguardo il
cazzo ci sono arrivato
sentite un attimo dove sarebbe traguardo
la vita ok [ __ ] tema riuscire tv
ok spinning la spal non so che cos'è
oddio io
cos'è sta roba non io la gara senza paga
devo rifarlo chiesto perché non ho
capito il senso allora se io parto e ciò
in vetrina il coach e non ho capito che
cosa dovrei fare qui e io ti odio che
cosa erika
[Musica]
hamster ball cos'è la dovrebbe essere la
ruota quella del criceto si vedono gli
occhi questo livello non lo so perché
vai così vai così
cos'è sta roba non ho che cadono che
caso devo riuscire arriva l'altro
parraga devo prendere una rincorsa
madonna mia un criceto farebbe di più
vaio ma che cazzo dice ce la puoi fare
se vuoi sei incastrata perché è una
bolla offesa raga devo riuscire il
nostro livello veramente epico do
riuscire a farlo con qualcuno
vai non lo sciacca con qualcuno di
atletico by cos'è ormai conta laga
impossibile vai vai vai vai vai vai se
no o mio dio
non ha senso 99 per cento impossible
mais team 99 per cento i costi possono
col padre new york e gli occhi cos'è
oddio raga ma senza mio dio sono
stuprato cosa fai hoc perché mi tieni la
testa perché perché york perché sono
stuprato da jack black non ha senso da
quando il 99 per cento il prossimo sono
così fatti raga che scultura è questa
fatemi capire cioè io sto pedalando
devo riuscire allora devo calcolare bene
i tempi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
non ci credo non ci credo
ecco la classe successo raga due momenti
epici in un sacco in un solo video c'è
una cosa fantastica
questo merito mi piace no mio dio
santissimo e ora che io vi giuro che si
livelli li amo sono fantastici e jungle
rock swing mi manca raga questo non
avevo ancora fatto con eddy vai ed il
rock swing son tutti i tuoi è cosa devo
fare ritorno all'indietro perfetto vai
così oh mio dio in mezzo alla giungla è
qui si scoprirono le vere origini di
eddy è in realtà lui e tarzan
ok ok perfetto sono atterrato qui questo
doveva o dio
cos'è oddio cos'è no cad demetz cosa
dovrei fare qui
adori avviare perfetta non ce l'abbiamo
fatta mai ad fai vedere al tuo antenato
che sei ancora capace di andare in zona
liana va il cos'è ok ragazzi so che ce
la faccio se stavolta ce lo fa eravamo
alla fine certi che potevo riuscirci
anche maledizione direi di andare su
mini game cos'è minigame un nuovo ancora
visto questo mini game oddio è un volto
a josè devo uccidere luke cm è una
cazzata questo perché posso appoggiarla
dove voglio la palla dalla botta mica
sulla morte c'è mica sono anna ma la
morte
porca [ __ ] che idiota è veramente
volevo dire io non l'avevo vista
l'ultima sono giustificate o il
sottogola di mezzo ok c'è col all'inizio
ce la possiamo fare no no è ok
devo riuscire niente tutte le tute di
tutte quante adesso anche questo
aspettate cari non ci sono più adesso
non ci sono più non sono più scusato non
c è co infatti ok ci siamo ragazzi
addio oddio è una cosa verrai a questo è
difficile tratto perché devo ci sono
sono contate le spade york
prendi di questa se ce l'ho fatta devo
si perfetto ce l'ho fatta devo andare
roadable devo prendere il punto rosso
c'è ma è difficilissimo raga perché se
ne manchi qualcuno tipo questo come fai
dopo beccarlo vai se l'ho preso l'ho
preso nel rompere castro preso chi è ma
i giochi
vai giù e tutti insieme no a ragazzo
livello è stato etico perché era tutti
insieme
kill your bones ora che a questo mi
ispira un casinò al nome devo riuscire
allora sono il padre di new edy al mio
capo ma cazzo è bene sono caduto maf
ancora ti butto giù affinché non era
legno boss mister era l'altro devo
prenderla in pieno da marco m bene se no
e cos'ha fatto che se la macabra cosa
sta succedendo perché che cazzo cos'è
successo
raga volevo provare a cercare fa vj
l'avevo già fatto una volta ma mi avete
detto che praticamente è pieno di
livelli dedicati a me suo ep i miei
scritti voglio provare a scrivere fa vj
a vedere che succede
ok ci siamo fa vj bene cosa dovrebbe
succedere adesso what the fuck cos'è
oh mio dio cioè ci sono 50 50 pagine 50
pagine di livelli cos'è o mio dio va
bene c'è un po di roba che cos'è la vj a
rapire il leggendario fa vj un dio
grazie va facciamo questo visto che mimì
cosa cosa devo fare cioè fa grandissimo
parigi grazia l'ho già fatto un rock
swing ma iniziava per rifacciamo dai
giacomelli con eddy ma vige riuscirà a
fare un livello 6
madonna questo è più di uno swing e
troppo figo mai la gamba ma inizia da
chi cds tua mamma mia
da riprendere la liana cioè io sono
riuscito a ripetta ma che cazzo
oddio cosa sta che acrobata non c'è non
ho veramente se riescono ma guarda te
cioè io sto viso lasciando e riprendendo
con la diana in una maniera assurda cioè
sono senza gambe tra l'altro ma non
voglio neanche sapere dove dove cielo
infilata la liana però c'è il presidente
mi sono lasciato dalla liane ci sono
risalito tre o quattro volte se non so
come ho fatto
e poi sono riuscito a cadere così ho
fatto delle cose epiche allo stesso
tempo è e poi sono uscito a morire come
un idiota non si sa come va bè rai che
ha visto che sono tantissimi direi di
provare anche altro
e fantastico c'è una cosa assurda
direi di provare a fare una donna ma ce
ne sono alcuni che sono 16.000 16 mila
partite cioè ma come cazzo e poi sono
miei livelli
c'era che per famiglia e vediamo se
riesce a fare questo pista istigando
comunque vada se il migliore ma come
vuoi che vada se sono con steve e cioè
ricordati che siano porca [ __ ] steve
non possiamo fare ste figure
all'edizione dai che sono a un livello
che mi stanno istigando non posso
perdere madonna madonna
cosa credevi che non si riusciva grazie
mille per il livello però hai poca
fiducia in me fratello mio vj kill dem
ol cos'è questo mi ispira un casino dal
nome deve essere una cosa assurda alla
kill the mall
ps per farvi già perfetto easy medium
hard ok questo è la difficoltà ma chuck
non ho ciak era facile prefettura dove
anche gli occhi è facile o mio dio
anche il pallone e medio no no
come ho fatto a morire che i nas tardi
non è giusta snav perché raga non ci
riuscirò mai più a mio zio ma che cazzo
ma che è possibile sapere raga questo è
peggio degli il prossimo è volato un
braccio agli occhi ma chi se ne fotte
devo riuscire ma no no no olè olè olè se
ok ce l'andremo dovrei avercela fatta
credo se riesco a passarli sopra
perfetto no ce l'ha quanti ce ne
quanti ce ne o mio dio
vabbè ragazze prima non riuscivo a farne
un adesso ne faccio un miliardo
questa charmat rangone devo riuscire ad
andare avanti no no no
lo zio che scappava addio mio io ho un
pene o un bel
l'ho fatta vabbè avevo lascia il posto
del pene cioè ci credo solo per farvi j
vediamo se riesce a fare questo livello
va bene tutti che mistico in questo ok
perfetto allora tu non mi puoi saluto
altre gote ciao tre cotte cosa devo fare
qui sono con steve se tu mi stai mi stai
sfidando cioè tu credi che io non ce la
faccia e devo saltare sto punto qui
oddio oddio non secret by steve vai
steve vai dove dove dove cazzo è la pena
non c'è più sono andato con grandissimo
è una battaglia persa alla fine mio dio
ma come fanno a pensare che non ci
riesca
mi dispiace a quiz su famiglia era che
voglio vedere se stavolta ci hanno
azzeccato che l'ultimo il quiz è stato
qualcosa di assurdo
e vabbè allora veloce qui stesso famigia
di una muffa vj preferisce la patata o
la nutella
vediamo se stavolta ci hanno azzeccato
andiamo sulla patata allora vediamo se
bravi stavolta ci siete cazzo perché
l'ultima volta avete sbagliato di brutto
rallenta si sono fermo vabbè andiamo
avanti
il personaggio preferito l'iva vj e il
padre di york steve ma che cazzo
niente contro il padre di york che dato
che non sto comandando adesso non vorrei
che se la prendesse andasse contro
qualcosa per farmi uccidere raga io
direi di trovare un
se riesco un uno sguardo truce ancora
non ho fatti e poi un po ok boltro ci
vuole è ce ne vuole uno almeno in ogni
livello di è più rischiosi come uno
sport trovo devo fare anche quello dopo
è ok melone ho trovato un po trovato con
melone devo riuscire a farcela dato che
no cazzo che sfiga dai che cade dai che
cade dai che cade soffiate tutti rai
cazzo dai cazzo
[Musica]
ho vinto se riesco a trovare un
maledetto ok ce l'ho fatta allora su
world trade and stuff
devo riuscire madonna questo è
fantastico devo riuscire a vincere
almeno in un video di happy days ci
vuole uno smart rosano non son contento
e magari sono rimasti nello stesso punto
un po meglio allora aspettative spade
bastardo sono più sono più pesanti
non riesco a lanciarle recentemente a
piccolo l'ho preso e ad uscire ma perché
se spada in un po la nomi che è
impossibile se schneider haga sono più
raga faranno arma al folletto che cazzo
è successo è do not break your leghe non
lo decido io sia un altro potevo fare
direttamente questo c'era anche il bold
trova beh facciamo di nuovo questo se
tiro qua guadagno le palle allora lo
faccio subito grazie
devo dov'è la vittoria laggiù perfetto
dove no no no no no no ok ok piano raga
calmi
ok tre secondi morte cosa vuol dire tre
secondi morte non sono morto
meglio così sinceramente se guen lo
prego presa non l'ho presa andato troppo
avanti bastarda devo prenderla
mariah non si può raggiungere la
vittoria vado troppo avanti è come noi
come voi che faccia allora aspettate un
attimo devo riuscire all'ultimo pallone
ce la posso fare
c'è la foto nomine escape box raga
faccio questo e poi finisco cosa devo
scappare prima che si spari ok
impossibile ci annuncia farò mai
sì sì oddio va indiana spa india ma che
cazzo impossibile raga devo riuscire a
saltare non ce la farò mai e in apposite
allora devo riuscire a usare una tattica
se magari socio e faccio finta di essere
morto non mi beccano ok se sono ancora
vivo lo sapeva che avrebbe funzionato
testo ho visto e vabbè ragazzo l'abbiamo
fatta
ricordatevi la casella e situazioni
difficili spingetevi marte e funziona
sempre
vabbè ragazzi io direi di concludere qui
l'episodio 6 viso è piaciuto come al
solito lasciato come mi sono dimenticato
di ringraziarvi per il 50 mila iscritti
la caverà mente grazie infinite è un
traguardo assurdo ragazze riesco
lo speciale dovrebbe uscire sabato
questo che arriva è dato che è l'ultima
settimana di scuola sono impegnatissimo
con i compiti ma se ci riescono faccio
uscire questo sabato raga scusatemi ma
veramente sono impegnatissima ma farò il
possibile vi giuro comunque grazie mille
per il traguardo raggiunto siete
fantastici come al solito comunque se il
video è piaciuto lasciate un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
non i video trovate nella descrizione
sera siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi
noi ci vediamo in un prossimo video
bella ragazzi
[Musica]